welcome back everyone this is part two
in our series on in context learning I
thought I'd cover some Core Concepts for
the most part I think these concepts are
a review for you all but I thought it
would be good to kind of get them into
our common ground to help us think about
them as we think about what's happening
with in-context learning techniques
to start let's just establish some
terminology I think there's a lot of
variation in how these terms are used in
the literature and I thought I would
just try to be clear about what I mean
with these various crucial phrases
let's start with in context learning
when I say in context learning I mean a
frozen language model
performs a task only by conditioning on
the prompt text it's Frozen that is
there are no gradient updates the only
mechanism we have for learning is that
we input some text and that puts the
model in a temporary state that we hope
is useful for having it generate things
that we regard as useful for our task
few shot in context learning is a
special case of that this is where the
prompt includes examples of the intended
Behavior and no examples of the intended
Behavior were seen in training
of course we are unlikely to verif be
able to verify two in this modern era
where models are trained on massive
amounts of text will have no idea
typically what was in those training
data sets often we have no ability to
audit them and so we might not be sure
whether we're actually doing fuse shot
in context learning but this is the
ideal and the spirit of this is that if
models have seen examples of this type
in training it's hardly few shot anymore
the whole point is to see whether with
just a few instances models can do what
we want them to do
[Music]
I'll also acknowledge that the term few
shot is used in more traditional
supervised learning settings in the
sense of training on a few examples with
gradient updates and so I'm just
emphasizing that when I say few shot in
this lecture series I'm always going to
mean few shot in context learning with
no gradient updates
zero shot in context learning is another
special case this is where the prompt
includes no examples of the intended
Behavior but I'll allow that it could
contain some instructions and as before
item two no examples of the intended
Behavior were seen in training again
we're unlikely to be able to verify too
so we won't know whether this is truly
zero shot but the concept is clear
for item one this is more interesting
I'll say that formatting and other
instructions that you include in the
prompt are a kind of gray area but let's
allow them in the zero shot category
what I mean by that is that as you give
more elaborate instructions you might in
effect be demonstrating the intended
Behavior but the other side of this is
that instructions are conceptually very
different kinds of things for machine
learning in general than actual
demonstrations and so it's interesting
to separate out the case where you
demonstrate directly from the case where
you just describe the intended Behavior
and so while that will allow mirror
descriptions to still be zero shot
[Music]
another reminder
is just how GPT and other models work we
covered this in the unit on contextual
representation and I thought I'd just
remind us so that this is front of Mind
as we think about the in-context
learning techniques
here's a slide repeating the auto
regressive loss function that these
models use and again the essence of this
is that scoring happens on the basis of
the embedding representation for the
token that we want to predict at time
step t
and the hidden state that the model has
created up until the time step
proceeding T those are the two crucial
ingredients
and here's how that plays out for GPT
style models in the context of training
and I'll show you first training with
teacher forcing this slide is a repeat
from one we had in the contextual
representations unit but again I want to
issue a reminder here
at the bottom we have one hot vectors
representing the sequence of tokens in
the sequence that we are using for
training normally we represent these as
actual sequences of tokens but I'm
trying to remind us at a mechanical
level of how these things actually
operate so these are one hot vectors and
those are used to look up vectors in our
embedding layer that's given in Gray
here and the result of that lookup is a
vector and at this stage I have given
the names of the vectors according to
our vocabulary but again what we really
have here is a sequence of vectors
those vectors are the input to the big
Transformer model that we're using for
language modeling I've shown a kind of
schematic of this and the one thing I've
highlighted is the pattern of attention
mechanisms recall that when we're doing
Auto regressive modeling we can't look
into the future with those dot product
attention mechanisms only into the past
and so you see that characteristic
pattern for the attention connections
so we do all our processing with all
these Transformer blocks and then at the
very top we're going to use our
embedding layer again
the labels so to speak are again our
sequence offset by one from the sequence
that we have at the bottom here so like
this was the start token we use that to
predict the then at the next time step
the comes in down here and that is the
basis for predicting rock rock comes in
down here predicts rules rules down here
and then we finally predict the end of
token sequence so we're offset by one
using the previous context to predict
the next token
and again I've given these as one hot
vectors because those one-hot vectors
are the actual learning signal
and those are compared for learning with
the vector of scores that the model
produces at each time step scores over
the entire vocabulary and it's the
difference between the one hot vector
and the score Vector that we use to get
gradient updates to improve the model
again I'm emphasizing this because we
tend to think that the model has
predicted tokens but in fact predicting
tokens is something that we make them do
what they actually do is predict score
vectors
so what's depicted on the slide here is
teacher forcing
there's an interesting thing that
happened at this time step where the
score Vector actually put the highest
score on the final element here which is
different from the one hot Vector that
we wanted to predict
in teacher forcing I still use this one
hot Vector down at the next time step to
continue my predictions there are
versions of training where I would
instead use the one hot Vector that had
a one here at the next time step and
that can be useful for introducing some
diversity into the mix and that is also
a reminder that these models don't
predict tokens they predict score
vectors and in principle even in
training we could use their predicted
score vectors in lots of different ways
we could we could do some beam search
and use the entire prediction that they
make over beam search to do training for
future time steps we could pick the
lowest scoring item if we wanted right
this is all up to us because
fundamentally what these models do is
predict score vectors
[Music]
that was for training our actual focus
is on Frozen language models for this
unit and so we're really going to be
thinking about generation so let's think
about how that happens
let's imagine that the model has been
prompted with the beginning of sequence
token and the and it has produced The
Token Rock
we use Rock the one hot Vector there as
the input to the next time step we
process that and make another prediction
in this case we could think of the
prediction as roles
comes in as a one hot Vector at the next
time step and we continue our
predictions
that's the generation process again I
want to emphasize that at each time step
the model is predicting score vectors
over the vocabulary
and we are using our own rule to decide
what token that actually corresponds to
what I've depicted here is something
that you might call Greedy decoding
where the highest scoring token at each
time step is used at the next time step
but again that just reveals that there
are lots of decision rules that I could
use at this point to guide generation
I mentioned beam search before that
would be where we do a rollout and look
at all the score distributions that we
got for a few time steps and pick one
that seems to be the best scoring across
that whole sequence which could yield
very different behaviors from the
behavior that we get from greedy
decoding and if you look at the apis for
our really large language models now
you'll see that they have a lot of
different parameters that are
essentially shaping how generation
actually happens and that is again a
reminder that generation is not really
intrinsic to these models what's
intrinsic to them is predicting score
vectors over the vocabulary and the
generation part is something that we
make them do via a rule that we decide
separately from their internal structure
so that queues up a kind of nice
question that you could debate with your
fellow researchers and friends and loved
ones and people out in the world do
auto-regressive language models simply
predict the next token
well your first answer might be yes
that's all they do and that is a
reasonable answer
however
we just saw that it's more precise to
say that they predict scores over the
entire vocabulary at each time step and
then we use those scores to compel them
to predict some token or other we compel
them to speak in a particular way and
that feels more correct at a technical
level
and you might reflect also that they
actually represent data in their
internal and output representations and
very often in NLP it's those
representations that we care about not
any particular generation process and
that just points to the fact that
autoregressive LMS do a lot more than
just speak so to speak
but on balance I would say that it's
saying they simply predict the next
token might be the best in terms of
science communication with the public
you can talk in nuanced ways with your
fellow researchers about what they're
actually doing and how they represent
examples but out in the world it might
give people the best mental model if you
simply say that they predict the next
token based on the tokens that they have
already generated and the ones that you
put in it's an appropriately mechanistic
explanation that I think might help
people out in the world calibrate to
what's actually happening
because we should even remind ourselves
as we see more impressive behaviors from
these models that underlyingly the
mechanism is uniform if you prompt the
model with better late than and it says
never
transparently we can see that that's
just a kind of high probability
continuation of the prompt sequence
when you have every day I eat breakfast
lunch and it will probably say dinner
and you might immediately think ah that
reflects some World Knowledge that the
model has but as far as we know all that
really is is a continuation of the
sequence with a high probability token
and it's high probability because of
regularities in the world for the
language model this is simply a high
probability continuation
and again when you prompt it with the
president of the US is and it gives you
the name of a person as an answer that
might look like it has stored some
knowledge about the world and maybe
there is a sense in which it has but as
far as we know and mechanistically that
is simply offering a high probability
continuation of the sequence so when you
get to something like the key to
happiness is
and it offers you an answer that seems
insightful you should again remind
yourself that that is just a high
probability continuation of the input
sequence based on all the training
experience that the model has had and we
really have no ability to audit what
those training sequences were like the
mechanism is uniform there might be
something interesting happening in terms
of representation kind of under the hood
here
but we should remind ourselves that
really it's just high probability
continuations for all of these cases
the final core concept that I want to
mention here is that one that we're
going to return to at various points
throughout this series and this is this
notion of instruction fine tuning this
is uh from the the blog post that
announced chat GPT it's a description of
how they do instruct fine tuning for
that model there are three steps here
and I think the thing to highlight is
that in step one we have what looks like
fairly standard supervised learning
where at some level we have human
curated examples of prompts with good
outputs and the model is trained on
those instances and then at step two we
again have humans coming in now to look
at model outputs that have been
generated and rank them according to
Quality conditional on the prompt input
so that's two stages at which people are
playing a crucial role we have left
behind the very pure version of the
distributional hypothesis that says just
doing language model training of the
sort I described before on entirely
unstructured sequence symbols gives us
models that are powerful we have now
entered back into a mode where a lot of
the most interesting behaviors are
certainly happening because people are
coming in to offer direct supervision
about what's a good output given an
input it's not magic when these models
seem to do very sophisticated things it
is largely because they have been
instructed to do very sophisticated
things by very sophisticated humans that
is important in terms of understanding
why these models work and I think it's
also important for understanding how
various in-context learning techniques
behave because increasingly we're seeing
a feedback loop where
the kinds of things that we want to do
with our prompts are informing the kinds
of things that happen in the supervised
learning phase making them more powerful
again it's not a mysterious discovery
about how large language models work but
rather just a reflection of the kinds of
instruct fine tuning that are very
commonly happening now